[Music]
so a student's plan gun violence
protests let's be honest no one trusts
each other in this debate if you say
sensible gun control others here code
for you're taking away my guns if you
say protect my gun rights others will
call you a murderer I say let's make it
simple we need to harden soft targets
big companies do this already they're
surrounded by guards so should schools
it's a trillion dollar industry waiting
to happen bring back psychiatric
hospitals right now they house less than
1/10 of the people they did 60 years ago
a florida agency looked at this latest
creep in 2016 but they let him go do you
want to bet it was based on space that
he wasn't worth a bed we also must last
the media footprint of killers and
reduced the appeal for infamy creeps
obsess over the fame of previous creeps
it's their drug let's take away that
drug we need to think offensively
instead of asking how do we rig the
system to stop perps from getting guns
ask how do we tag the perps and keep
them from getting guns we want to get
the bad eggs not the law-abiding ones
you see the difference Florida was
preventable the fiend was all red flags
perfect for a database of nuts and perps
who shouldn't get guns this guy had no
violent felonies so a civil tag is what
could have nailed him based on testimony
from cops students school officials a
judge could then issue a civil court
order rather than defensively cast a
wide net that catches tons of fish we
don't want you tag the right people who
are placed into one single database
along with violent felons if you're in
it no gun and you violate the database
that's mandatory prison time so this
isn't just see something say something
it's actually do something so by all
means protest but it won't do much when
you're targeting the haystack while
letting the needle slip through you know
that we learned about the FBI screw-up
Kimberly yeah and now about this Florida
mental health agency that had examined
this this guy in 2016 but they didn't
hospitalized him the article I read
didn't say why but I'm assuming if there
was room for him why not
hold them for 72 hours they didn't even
do that yeah and that's the problem so
they're gonna have to do some analysis
on that they're gonna have to go back
and talk to the people who is in charge
of intake who's the supervisor on duty
who actually had contact you know with
him and made that determination that's
the only way we're gonna get better
unless you do these kind of like
thoughtful deliberate and you know deep
probing investigations to figure out how
we can do it better for the next time
because this this cannot continue to
happen especially when someone is
basically screaming out for help
presenting these problems I'm having
this like a violent you know ideation
and saying that they want to become a
school shooter they have the weapons
they have the means and ability to do so
they go in and they're in front of a
mental health professor professional the
FBI has them on the screen so it wasn't
just like on one level that this was a
fail it's on multiple levels that people
could have caught this and stopped it
and kept him in yeah and held him maybe
72 hours Greg and then out again it was
self harming Juan I guess on snapchat
it's saying he was gonna bike I mean
this guy had more red flags and I don't
know a red flag factory right and and it
we talked about like we look at Vegas I
don't know how we could have prevented
that that guy capitalized on obscurity
you know no one knew but here this is a
guy basically telling you what he's
going to do and nobody listened well the
question is whether or not you take him
seriously and of course his civil
liberties because what we know is back
going back to the 80s and Megan earlier
right well that's that was the point
that they institutionalize people right
and they said you know what folks have a
right to not have their freedoms taken
away because you deem them to be somehow
mentally incompetent we're not sure who
you're picking on who you're not picking
on etc but I couldn't agree with you
more I think that's a danger an
increasing danger to the society when
you have so many it's not only people
who are you know of a murderous instinct
but I think that we have high rates of
people who for example veterans who have
you know traumatic syndrome as homeless
people I see more homeless people all
over the country to me than ever and I
think that's a lot of mental illness I
will say I think it's great that the
young people are willing to march in
Washington I think that hopefully
we'll change the tenor of the debate
because maybe if young people are saying
you've got to do something it will
appeal to people who as you point out
are just locked into oh you're gonna
take my guns are you gonna people say
wait you know what gun owners NRA
members think that background checks can
be done better and President Trump has
now said today or his aides have said
that he's interested in doing something
to strengthen our background check to
that point Jesse I think it's important
that the these like suggestions that I
made in other people like I think David
French wrote a good piece for National
Review on on Jesus that violence
restraining orders yes that it comes
from the conservative libertarian side
because nobody trusts it coming from the
other side because everybody's so we
hear the the dog whistle that they're
coming to take the guns away right it's
true it's like a pre 9/11 mindset when
it comes to school shootings after 9/11
everybody realized they were stovepiping
all of this information all these other
agencies weren't sharing anything with
each other but now you have the police
the school the Department of Children
and Families everybody knows something
even the FBI and no one's sharing this
information so you look at a threat
matrix on a kid like this he's diagnosed
autistic he's diagnosed depressed he's
diagnosed mentally unstable by the
agency that looked at him and someone
who was an at-risk adult because of
mental instability
he was developmentally disabled and you
have a mobile crisis unit that is
dispatched to the school he's expelled
for violent behavior at the school the
police are called dozens of times to the
house if you add that up all those
different things and you say you know if
someone qualifies for 60% of all those
things then well they don't get a gun
yeah maybe it'd make him wait a few
years before he's able to purchase a
weapon like that at that age
so obviously we need gun control but it
shouldn't be taking guns away from
people or not manufacturing the ar-15 we
cant even ban gun bump stocks after
Vegas but we should increase background
checks and make sure these information
or the information is shared
appropriately yeah I think the thing to
worry is that whenever gun control comes
up the law abiding gun owner thinks it's
about them
and the idea is to switch it so you're
saying no we're it's almost like stop
and frisk or community policing but
applying to this I think so and I
actually think that it's not necessarily
a congressional move here because the
states are the policy innovators and
incubators and I would think that this
is mostly a states rights issue so it's
not like you would have to wait for
Congress and DC to actually move forward
on something like gun violence
restraining orders or these red flag
laws you could actually do that in
Tallahassee and that could happen in
Florida or you might do it in another
state and that's an experiment that's
where all the experiments happen in the
states and then you can figure out a way
if you want to move it forward sometimes
the federal government will do things
like tying transportation funds in order
to get a state to comply with something
like the drinking age or something like
that but if this were to work in a
certain place if you try it out
somewhere and you have somebody like the
mother from Connecticut and Sandy Hook
know she tried to get help she didn't
know where to go there's also a real
concern about cuts to Medicaid which is
where people a lot of people get their
mental health help if they're if they're
going to get any I hadn't heard the
autism diagnosis and I think that I
don't know enough about it and I think
that we've there's a tendency to then
extrapolate that into into others but I
would say this on the communication
standpoint the kids staying in this
story makes it very hard for the media
to ignore it so they get they know that
and I think they've been pretty smart
they're working together they're using
their social networks in order to gather
not just input in Tallahassee they're
calling for a march on March 24th that
sounds weird a march in March 24th and
the the more they stay in this story it
will be harder for people to ignore but
I don't necessarily think that this is
just a congressional issue I think that
you can get more done faster at the
state level yeah the things I think the
media doesn't have to be this is a
highly visual protest especially if it's
going to be nationwide and the women's
March it's getting behind it which is
then gonna raise suspicions that it's
more of a political event if the women's
March all one and a liberal one and I
think that's an error that's an error
and also an error too
continually talked about repealing the
Second Amendment because that's never
gonna happen
but you hear that I think if the medium
may be focused on why he wasn't placed
in the hospital how did the FBI drop the
ball as well as these protests right but
you want to make sure that this isn't
going to be you know a direct you know
full-on assault on the second a gun grab
because then that's you know it's right
but given the political differences in
ideological differences to try to use
this as a vehicle to try to confiscate
guns and there's situations where
somebody can just make a complaint
against the neighbor something like yeah
and then you have to be very careful
that it'll be like take something once
you get on the list yes how Nord er to
get off of it and that will be hard but
again I think that this one of the
states could start this yeah and it's
simple and if it's a civil you know tag
that means it's the bars lower and it's
always it's about these people it's
about the guy that you know it's like
nobody knows what to do with the problem
you know Emily mentioned the state
agency that went and visited this guy
after he was posting pictures on social
media of him cutting himself saying he
wanted to do violence and buy a gun he
was wearing long sleeves at the time and
the reason that didn't involuntarily
commit him was because they never even
checked and looked at his sleeves Hey
Dude pull your sleeves up yeah there's a
really pathetic visit by the state
agency I think you know if not thorough
and they're pressed and they have so
many cases and then they go in and they
do a rush I mean I want to tell you
about it that case that I don't for me
anyway if they didn't even check this
little girl who had been beaten then her
scalp was duct taped back on the house
you know why you brought up vets and the
problems that they had there's a
positive argue me too maybe on how to
use vets this is from Tyrus I was a
co-host on my show brought up this as a
sick a practical solution when 9/11
happened the planes at the tower's
airports were changed forever
we got the TSA our children are getting
hit it's time to change the schools
forever and there is a population out
there and I checked only had they didn't
have the new stats out but last year
stats was 4.3 percent unemployment for
returning
in this country that's 435,000 trained
men who have eyes and ears we need to
have them at the schools is that a good
I mean I like it I think it's a great
idea what do you think one well I know
the the criticism is that if you police
the schools that so intensely then
everything that a young person does
becomes a criminal act rather than a
teenager acting up because all of a
sudden there's a cop there and now
there's a criminal record and so
essentially you are you know
institutionalizing the school in a way
that i don't think schools are intended
kids are if i understand what tires are
saying is they wouldn't be there in
order to have disciplinary action
oversight they would just be there to
protect mm-hmm well I it what happens is
if you have police there then I think
there's the school Authority police but
but I think that let me just say the
bigger point to me is the one that you
were talking about earlier which is
basically people get locked in to their
political boxes right here and that
people will say you're coming for my
guns now to my mind when I think about
the NRA and its role here I don't see
how you get away from it because they
are so heavily politicized and they put
so many so many dollars into Republican
candidates they they back Republic I
think the NRA influence is a little
overrated because unions and and Planned
Parenthood's a lot more money but if any
president could do something on this
issue I think Donald Trump could here's
the thing they're very supportive of
this and if he wants to give a little on
background checks I think the larger
would be open to yeah absolutely the
question is would his right wing be open
to it
would the nra be open to it because I
think that so many in the case of gun
owners are single-issue voters and
that's the only issue they see the whole
world through that prism and are easily
threatened and I think that if Trump if
others that the NRA was finally say
listen here is a reasonable step that we
can get behind it would make a huge
difference because remember we didn't
get bump stocks we haven't had any added
steps in terms of the mental illness
issue that Greg's talking about today
Medicare as Dana was talking about less
opportunities for coverage for mental
health issues to me that this is a right
staring us in the face we don't have to
wonder about it yeah it's just that we
haven't really had good practical
solutions from the loudest voices when
you even look at what the ACLU came out
against the Obama the bill because of
the K it was a defensive move it was at
casting a wide VAT on to people who
can't fill out their Social Security
benefits because of a disability this
crowd is not the type of crowd that
shoots up schools so anyway president